it is wednesday 6 41
time for warren cup of joe and metro
sheriff joe lombardo is joining us live
today from metro headquarters good
morning sheriff it's good to see you
alex good to see you all right we want
to start with this today sheriff the
murder trial of former minneapolis
police officer derek shovin
in the death of george floyd it started
last week so when that verdict does come
down no matter what happens
there is a strong chance for
demonstrations nationwide
is metro preparing for protests here
locally
yeah i would say that we are i mean
fingers crossed like everybody else
but i think the important piece on this
is to be proactive
and i believe we have at metro been
proactive in this and and that's
communication with the community
excuse me i think it's very important to
talk about this right not to
keep our fingers crossed and hope it
doesn't happen i i
in traditional police work we prepare
for
the inevitable and you know we uh we
over
commit and then hopefully you can just
de-escalate
if it doesn't turn out the way is is
expected
um in this case there could be a
plethora of
happenings or decisions you know
acquittal um
an indictment uh dismissal
you know even if there is an indictment
people may not be happy with the
level of indictment so that's the
important thing to consider so
what we've done here at metro we
proactively met with the community
uh on several occasions prior to today
and we uh hope for the best moving
forward and what i mean by hope for the
best we hope for the best that
the community is holding hands and
they're together and they're talking
about it versus
causing destruction as a result of it we
have pretty good history here
in community interaction and community
engagement
and if you saw last week we did the
metro multicultural advisory committee
uh press conference and that was a press
conference um
orchestrated by them not me not the
government per se
um and reaching out to the community and
say hey have patience
we've had success here in the past with
controversial issues
because we've had that patient and we
relied on metro's response
right now sheriff state lawmakers are
considering several bills that would
make it more difficult for police to use
deadly force
including when dispersing protests what
are your thoughts on that
well i think it's it's something that
has constantly be looked at
um you know reference the on the heels
of
george floyd in the incident there in
milwaukee um or minneapolis the uh
we constantly have to talk about it and
here's the reason why
the use of deadly force is a very big
issue it's a very important issue and
it's important that the police
departments
explore the sanctity of life associated
with the use of deadly force
and and and what i'm proud of
here at lvmpd is we've been very
proactive in that space
and it isn't because you know we're the
best of the best i even though i agree
with that
and i would say that but it's because we
had warts
upon us in the past and we realized what
was
occurring in the deadly force base and
then we had to do something about it so
we've been very proactive in placing
policies and
training and procedures in place to
make sure that we're utilizing deadly
force appropriately
and not just because we can um and
i think we're progressive in that space
and so if you look at the legislature
back to your original question
um they're addressing those issues but
those issues
are more in line with law enforcement
statewide versus lb and pd
a lot of the bills have been adopted
adapted and modified to match
our policy here at lbmpd to make it a
statewide function versus
uh an individual function and you know
and then the important piece is the duty
to render aid the duty to intervene
those are the key components associated
with
george floyd's incident and those
issues that we've addressed previously
yeah and it certainly has become a
larger conversation since
george floyd's death last year and it
should be so
uh our last question here today sheriff
we've talked about a spike in car thefts
and break-ins the past few months
do you know what's behind this increase
does metro see a trend there
uh well that's that's a great question
and to answer your question
uh no and but we could surmise in a
couple of different ways um yes there
has been a significant increase 25
across the board in vehicle thefts uh
lower a lot lower than that in actual uh
auto burglaries around two percent
increase so when i say 25 percent that's
a big number because
on an annual basis we average around 7
000 uh vehicle thefts a year
so if you put that in you know the the
math associated with that that's a big
deal
and uh so we're addressing it we're
looking at it and i think part of it is
because people are out and about more um
vehicles are being utilized more
a reference post covid and this
new phenomenon that's going on with
catalytic converters and they're
in the rare earths that's are located in
those converters
uh and how much they cost now per pound
in years past so there's a you know they
may be stealing the car
to eventually obtain the catalytic
converter versus crawling under it and
stealing it
at the location where it's parked so we
haven't been able to put our finger on
it yet but we're paying attention and
i think the important piece on this is
to educate the public make them aware
this is occurring
and be more vigilant associated with
target harden
uh their individual vehicles i mean just
this morning on my way here
i pull in the convenience store to get a
cup of joe
and and there was an individual in the
store left their car running out in
front of the store
you know so they could run and run out
but that's what people look for
that's they sit in parking lots and pay
attention to that or if you leave your
keys in your car
in front of your house or in your garage
those are the kind of things that you
need to be aware of and make it harder
and more difficult for a crook to do
what they do yes and don't leave the car
running
all right sheriff lombardo it's great to
see you thank you so much sir
have a great morning good morning thank
you alex all right if you have a
question for sheriff jill and barter you
can send it to us on our website
8newsnow.com
morning cup of joe is every wednesday
right here on good day las vegas